[Music]
this picture seen from far away looks
like a shape and this is the coat of
arms of the emblem of Trinity Hall this
College which is founded in 1350 1350 by
the way is a significant date because
it's the year after thirteen forty nine
and thirty forty nine is the year of the
Great Plague in London one of the great
plagues and that's that wiped out the
entire and lower generation in in London
and some people thought it was an act of
God but the founder of this college
Bishop Bateman so that the new
generation lawyers had to be retrained
and that's why the five colleges founded
in the first place but anyway we don't
have to have that in recording so you
will have a very strange object and this
is the coat of arms of twenty ho if you
look closely it consists of eight and
ones oh this is a little tube
irregularity here but otherwise it's
followed by zero zero zero zero and ends
in a 1 this turns out to be a prime and
the number of digits is prime is 1350
which is the year of the foundation of
the college this was a gift from Jeff
Mackey whom I didn't know personally but
my senior colleague Tom Khanna did he
was a junior research fellow in there
was a postdoc of this college who came
maybe 20 years ago I am told by Tom and
then when a fellow of the college leaves
the college is traditional for that
fellow to leave some gift to the College
and usually eating it has to do the
subject and he rather enterprising Lee
left this gift to the College in the
coat of arms of Trinity Howe with lotsa
no two zeros at the end but with one and
which is a prime now how surprising is
that I'm really listening oh of somebody
who not only had this idea but actually
implemented this idea and I think even
today it's a bit difficult to check that
this number is a prime I mean there are
lots of Prime's in the world of special
types for example Mersenne primes and
what-have-you and for which the
algorithm for checking that they are
prime checking and primarily is a very
well-known piece of mathematics but this
is a fairly sort of random primum e
starts with 8 8
and so and so how do you discover such a
thing is prime and the purpose of his
game of course was to hit the prime
exactly at 1350 this is because it's the
year of the foundation of college so you
can't really found fine tune and lead a
number of digits that's why I think
there's an irregularity here in the
beginning zero followed by six to one
and we are still looking for the special
significance of the number six to one
I'm sure there is some cosmic importance
to this number as well what you are
attached with to be honest it's sitting
in the lunchroom but I think most
fellows don't notice its presence it's
just sitting there among some
dictionaries and books on the side of
the yeah of the table and every once in
a while when somebody like you who has
interesting science and who has a
mischievous aspect to the personality
visit the college I love to show this to
the people and they're all kind of
amazed again not only that somebody had
an idea but somebody actually
implemented this whole thing is it's
really amazing since recording with
Tadashi we've shared a bit more light on
the identity of the mysterious prime
number creator jf McKee it is in fact
James McKee here he is around the time
he was a research fellow in pure
mathematics at Trinity Hall and here he
is now where he's a full professor at
Royal Holloway I did chat with him on
the phone and by email and if you'd like
to find out more have a look in the
video description and handle behave
exactly the same way whereas 45 degrees
off
[Music]